hoffen auf die impfung zum ersten mal
darf ein pharmakonzern in deutschland
ein mittel gegen korona an menschen
testen die sommerferien und ein
fragezeichen macht es sinn urlaub zu
planen
und wenn ja wohin und angst vor einem
neuen dürre ja die wochenlange
trockenheit macht wald und
landwirtschaft jetzt schon zu schaffen
nachrichten sich das heute mit christian
sievers herzlich willkommen an diesem
mittwoch und guten abend hinein
ganz zentral im kampf gegen die korona
pandemie ist ein impfstoff überall auf
der welt suchen forscher mit hochdruck
danach und ein deutsches unternehmen ist
jetzt einen entscheidenden schritt
weiter
zum ersten mal darf hier ein möglicher
impfstoff am menschen getestet werden
aber das ist nur ein schritt in einer
langen reihe von versuchen gucken wir
uns das mal genauer an
jetzt wird an freiwilligen getestet ob
der wirkstoff auch verträglich ist der
nächste schritt wieder mit freiwilligen
soll zeigen ob die substanz wirkt und
welche dosis die beste ist
dann bekommen tausende die im funk und
erst dann wenn alles gut läuft kann
sollen impfstoff zugelassen werden
marion geiger und julia schröter
berichten hoffen auf den stich der das
corona virus besiegen kann
die forscher der mainzer firma biontech
arbeiten fieberhaft daran
sie haben viel erfahrung mit impfstoffen
konnten auf eine vorhandene basis
aufbauen dass es die erklärung warum wir
so schnell das go für den test am
menschen kam das paul ehrlich institut
zuständig für impfstoffe seien alle
voraussetzungen erfüllt in diesem fall
war es so dass die entsprechenden
präklinischen untersuchungen die
qualitätsgesicherte herstellung bereits
vorlagen geliefert wurden und durch
mehrfache beratungen und auch
vorabgenehmigung vorgänger waren wir
jetzt in der lage anfang dieser woche
eine klinische prüfung zu genehmigen
getestet werden vier verschiedene
impfstoffkandidaten diese enthalten
genetische informationen des erregers im
idealfall stellt der körper ohne krank
zu werden daraus proteine her
auf diese reagiert er und baut
abwehrstoffe auf der impfschutz beginnt
schon ende des monats soll die studie an
rund 200 gesunden probanden im alter von
18 bis 55 jahren beginnen
ja dieser schritt der ersten klinischen
phase ist sehr wichtig weil eben hier
die verträglichkeit getestet wird ein
solcher impfstoff muss natürlich
verträglich sein darf keine großen
nebenwirkungen zeigen
der gesundheitsminister spricht heute
von einer guten nachricht aber er bremst
auch deswegen ist mir beides wichtig zum
einen die botschaft dass wir eben schon
so weit sind auch in deutschland und
gleichzeitig die botschaft auch
einordnen
das ist gleichwohl noch monate dauern
wird
so ist im stoff entwicklung nun mal bis
tatsächlich ein impfstoff zur verfügung
steht wirksamkeit und verträglichkeit
das muss hand in hand gehen biontech
erwartet im juni erste ergebnisse sind
die gut kann der test in die nächste
phase gehen
es wäre ein wichtiger schritt auf dem
weg zu einem impfstoff auf den die welt
so dringend wartet bis geimpft werden
kann muss die pandemie auf anderen wegen
eingedämmt werden und da spielen die 400
gesundheitsämter in deutschland eine
tragende rolle
sie wissen wer positiv getestet wurde
und müssen dann kontaktpersonen suchen
eine sisyphos arbeit die auch jede menge
personal braucht in kind klinger hat das
in mittelhessen beobachtet es ist ein
riesenaufwand für die mitarbeiter des
gesundheitsamts hier in marburg sie
versuchen jeden der kontakt zu einem
koma-patienten hatte zu ermitteln und
anzurufen
im callcenter klingelt den ganzen tag
über das telefon
mögliche erkrankte zum beispiel suchen
hilfe hier unterstützen längst geschulte
studenten
anders ist die korona krise gar nicht zu
bewältigen
die leiterin des gesundheitsamtes ist
froh zwei drittel aller infektionen
konnten zurückverfolgt werden
doch allmählich fehlt personal wir
können nicht mehr
wir haben in der akuten krise alle
personen rein gegeben in das thema in
die bewältigung der krise und keine
keinen urlaub genommen kann resturlaub
genommen überstunden gemacht wir
arbeiten samstags und sonntags
mittlerweile durch ja und jetzt müssen
wir in die lange strecke kommen jetzt
müssen wir planen wir weiter arbeiten
können und so können wir das jetzt nicht
mehr leisten wenn wir keine hilfe
bekommen die pläne der politik die
gesundheitsämter künftig mehr zu
unterstützen ist für marburg genau der
richtige weg das sieht man auch im
landkreis gießen so nur wenige kilometer
entfernt
hier wurde direkt gegenüber vom
gesundheitsamt in einer turnhalle
im testzentrum eingerichtet und eine
corona schwerpunkt praxis wenn bald mehr
menschen getestet werden sollen wird man
auch hier mehr mitarbeiter brauchen und
mit den aktuellen lockerungen wird noch
ein ganz anderes thema wichtig wir
werden vermehrt auch angefragt werden
und beratend aktiv werden müssen wenn es
um die frage von hygienemaßnahmen geht
in einrichtung in schulen und so weiter
und so fort das wird die neue normalität
sein und dafür brauchen wir personal in
gießen arbeiten rettungsdienste ärzte
und das gesundheitsamt bereits eng
zusammen
doch genügend fachpersonal auf dauer zu
gewinnen
das ist für viele gesundheitsämter eine
große herausforderung
lange ging es hin und her dann preschten
einzelner bundesländer vor mit der
verpflichtung so genannten mund
nasenschutz zu tragen
und jetzt kommt die masken pflicht
bundesweit für fahrten mit bus und bahn
und beim einkaufen
diese alltags masken halten tröpfchen
zurück und können so dazu beitragen
andere vor einer ansteckung zu schützen
ein ersatz für die hygiene und
abstandsregeln sind sie aber nicht
betonen experten
unter besonderen umständen nie
entschuldigung erst das hier bei den
infizierten das ist ja ganz wichtig
steht deutschland etwas besser da als
gestern
zwar hat sich die so wichtige
reproduktions zahlen nicht verändert
weiterhin infiziert ein virus träger im
schnitt 0,9 andere menschen schätzt das
robert koch institut aber pro tag werden
immer weniger neuinfektionen gemeldet
seit wochen geht der trend da nach unten
auch im vergleich von gestern auf heute
rund 1200 neue infizierte sind es noch
insgesamt kommt die johns hopkins
universität auf 149.000 44 bestätigte
corona fälle in deutschland stand vor
einer halben stunde davon gelten 99.000
400 betroffene als genesen
5127 menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben unter besonderen
umständen heute ein besonderer tag im
parlament und
ungewohnte worte vom deutschen
gesundheitsminister wir werden in der
politischen debatte und auch in der
medialen debatte nach dieser coronel
lage alle miteinander viel verzeihen
müssen weil das glaube ich in der
bundesrepublikanischen geschichte noch
nie es gegeben hat dass unter so großen
unsicherheiten in so kurzer zeit so
weitgehende entscheidungen getroffen
werden mussten sagt jens spahn und es
gibt weitere entscheidungen der
regierung alle die gerade in der pflege
so viel leisten bekommen mehr geld und
mehr urlaub ab ersten juli soll für
pflegefachkräfte ein einheitlicher
mindestlohn von 15 euro gelten
streit zwischen union und spd gibt es
dagegen über die frage ob das
kurzarbeitergeld erhöht wird davon sind
hier aktuell hunderttausende abhängig
tendenz steigend christiane hübsch rat
mehr viele die seit wochen in kurzarbeit
sind rutschen in existenzsorgen soll der
staat hier kurzfristig aufstocken
die koalition ist der uneins und
verhandelt darüber zur stunde im
kanzleramt
für uns sozialdemokraten ist wichtig
dass wir für diejenigen arbeitnehmerin
arbeitnehmer die in kurzarbeit sind 160
prozent des gehalts bekommen und des
lohns dass das erhöht wird das für uns
die hauptforderung die spd schließt sich
damit einer gewerkschafts forderung an
statt 60 beziehungsweise 67 prozent mit
kind soll das kurzarbeitergeld auf 80
beziehungsweise 87 prozent steigen
die union ist gegen die pauschale
erhöhung die ard dafür
ich mache natürlich eine riesige
gerechtigkeitslücke auf zu den menschen
die jetzt ihre arbeit ganz verlieren
oder verloren haben nämlich dann würde
es eine deutliche differenz zwischen
kurzarbeit und arbeitslosengeld 1
die jungs kommen mit 60 prozent vom
nettolohn kann ich nicht 100 prozent der
kosten bezahlt das geht einfach nicht
und
wenn man überlegt wie stark der
niedriglohnsektor und deutschland
gewachsen ist und von mindestlohn 60
prozent zu bekommen dass es nicht
hinnehmbar
noch gibt es keine belastbaren zahlen
nur um fragen
laut dieser sind 14 prozent aller
befragten gerade in kurzarbeit
hochgerechnet auf alle arbeitnehmer
während das etwa vier millionen zum
vergleich in der finanzkrise gab es
maximal 1,44 millionen kurzarbeiter in
der bundestagsdebatte fordert die fdp
erhöhen ja aber nicht für jeden
ich glaube es ist richtig darüber zu
reden dort etwas zu tun wo 100 prozent
kurzarbeit und niedrige löhne
zusammenkommen nur eine corona hilfe von
vielen über die die koalitionsspitzen
heute abend im kanzleramt beraten genau
denn es gibt auch noch steuerhilfen für
gastronomie die sind der diskussion
schutzschirm für kommunen bafög hilfen
kita öffnungen also wirklich sehr viel
dabei der koalitionsausschuss trifft
sich jetzt im moment im kanzleramt theo
koll guten abend wird das eine lange
nacht in berlin
davon darf man glaube ich ausgehen die
tagesordnung ist er lang und mir wurde
als möglicher endpunkt 22 uhr oder sogar
ein uhr nachts genannt und das wundert
auch nicht wirklich denn wir wechsel
hier in berlin gerade von der phase der
quasi pandemie erstarrten einigkeit der
politik zurück in die
auseinandersetzungen unterschiedlicher
parteien und interessengruppen wem wie
bei den crooner folgen zu helfen ist das
kurzarbeitergeld ist er eine wichtige
punkte daneben geht es auch ganz
wesentlich darum wie hilft man der von
den schließungen besonders gebeutelten
gastronomie die union und vor allem die
csu möchte dafür die mehrwertsteuer auf
sieben prozent absenken
die spd sieht das aber auch skeptisch
denn eine steuersenkung helfen nur denen
wir etwas zu versteuern hätten besser
sein dann um einige monate verlängerte
zuschüsse insgesamt will die spd
deutlich mehr geld in die hand nehmen
aus der union hört man dagegen die
deutliche sorge dass die bundesregierung
auch weiterhin finanziell handlungsfähig
bleiben müsse wenn auch in den kommenden
monaten sei ja sicher noch zusätzlich
ist finanziell zu stemmen
wie gesagt es dürfte heute spät werden
auch heute wieder
dank berlin wir haben gleich noch mehr
zum thema corona etwa die frage nach dem
sommerurlaub bleiben aber erst noch
einen moment in berlin bei der politik
und mit dieser nachricht für die rund 21
millionen rentner in deutschland
sie bekommen im sommer wieder deutlich
mehr geld die bundesregierung hat eine
rentenanhebung beschlossen im westen um
3,45 prozent im osten um 4,20 prozent
kampfjets vom typ tornado von denen
haben sich die meisten armeen längst
verabschiedet und auch die bundeswehr
sucht nach ersatz
doch da gibt es streit
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer presse im alleingang vor und
setzte nicht nur auf europäische modelle
sondern auch auf lieferungen aus den usa
kritisiert der eigene koalitionspartner
die spd heute war das thema im
verteidigungsausschuss des bundestages
cornelia schiemenz annegret kramp
karrenbauer in der defensive die spd
wirft ihr vor sie hätte im alleingang
über die tornado nachfolge entschieden
ohne absprache und ohne das parlament zu
informieren
es gäbe sogar bereits gespräche mit den
amerikanern die verteidigungsministerin
dementiert das was ich heute im
ausschuss dargestellt habe worüber ich
gestern auch die ob leute informiert
habe ist keine auswahl entscheidung die
ich schon getroffen ist sondern ist ein
vorschlag den das fach dressur das
verteidigungsministerium macht damit wir
die nächsten schritte zur beschaffung
auch gehen können die über alt hatte
tornado -flotte muss ausgetauscht werden
das ministerium will neben europäischen
eurofightern auch 30 amerikanische
kampfjets vom typ f-18 kaufen auch daran
stößt sich die spd aus
industriepolitischer sicht wäre ein
europäisches modell wünschenswert wenn
wir aber zu dem ergebnis kommen dass das
nicht möglich sein sollte warum
entscheidet man sich dann nicht für das
modernste flugzeug auf den markt und
werden diesen fall der d35 sondern für
lediglich das zweit modernste flugzeug
das auf jeden fall nicht mehr die
gleiche art von zukunftsperspektive hat
die f 18 können mit atomwaffen bestückt
werden zum unmut der opposition
es ist jetzt zeit genau diese nukleare
teilhabe endlich aufzugeben
und genau diese chance sollte die
koalition jetzt ergreifen
der streit dürfte weiter schwelen eine
entscheidung über den kauf fällt erst
nach der nächsten wahl offen auch die
kosten noch ein bemerkenswerter termin
heute in berlin im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium
die sicherheitsexperten den bundestag
machen sich nämlich sorgen dass die
korona krise ausgenutzt wird um gezielt
panik zu schüren von menschen die
verschwörungstheorien aus dem netz
aufgreifen felix zimmermann ein
mobilfunkmast in irland die technik
durch brandstiftung zerstört
europaweit gibt es aktuell dutzende
solche brandanschläge auf telefonmasten
hintergrund ist eine
verschwörungstheorie danach gäbe ist das
virus gar nicht sondern strahlungen von
5 g masten seien für die todesfälle
verantwortlich
die anzahl von corona
verschwörungstheorien im netz ist
unüberschaubar
mal wird eine biowaffe hinter dem virus
vermutet man hat die pharmaindustrie ihn
geschaffen um geld zu verdienen
veranstaltungs verbote gebe es um die
afd mundtot zu machen so der afg
bundestagsabgeordnete stephan brandner
krude theorien doch sie können
gefährlich werden extremisten machen sie
sich zu nutze
im rechtsextremistischen spektrum vor
allem das thema migration aber auch sehr
oft antisemitismus hier verbreitet wird
andererseits in den linksextremen
kanälen sehen wir eine gewisse antiken
rhetorik und dann islamistischen
spektrum ist es vor allem sodass es
verwendet wird als rhetorik gegen den
westen oder gegen ungläubige
sicherheitsbehörden und politiker sehen
wegen der starken verbreitung der
theorie eine erhöhte gefahr von
terroranschlägen
daraus entstehen ernste gefahren weil
die leute aus diesen theorien dann ja
handlungs
muster ableiten und das kann dann im
einzelfall sehr gefährlich werden
aktuell tagt das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium des bundestages in
geheimer sitzung zum thema
sicherheitsgefahren in der korona krise
wir müssen alle analyseinstrumente
nutzen um die szene auszuleuchten um zu
verstehen und zu erkennen wo können tat
geneigte startbereite bewaffnete täter
schlummern jetzt dürfen wir uns unter
dem motto der kroner pandemie nicht
blenden lassen verschwörungstheorien
erscheinen oft harmlos doch sie können
verheerende folgen haben und jetzt zu
der wichtigen frage nachdem der
osterurlaub schon ausfiel was es mit den
sommerferien bis zum dritten mai gilt
vom auswärtigen amt wegen corona noch
eine weltweite reisewarnung so etwas gab
es noch nie
ende april soll entschieden werden wie
es danach weitergeht fernreisen nur
europa oder urlaub ausschließlich zu
hause
es geht ja nicht nur um erholung sondern
auch um sehr viel geld für urlaub geben
die deutschen über 70 milliarden euro
jedes jahr aus romanesco war sommer
urlaub die schönste zeit des jahres
doch diesmal alles anders zwischen
hoffen und bangen die stimmungslage
vieler deutscher eher als türkei aber
wir geben nicht auf wir warten einfach
bis zum schloss ab wohin soll es gehen
in europa ist zu geht nicht funktioniert
nicht also ich habe auch alles schon
abgesagt anwalt karimi spürt die
verunsicherung viele seiner klienten
haben den sommer urlaub schon gebucht
wollen wissen soll die pauschalreise
storniert werden sein rat den anbieter
kontaktieren im zweifelsfall noch
abwarten
wenn ich jetzt aber meine reise für juni
storniere ist noch gar nicht final klar
ob die reise jetzt stattfinden kann oder
nicht das heißt wer jetzt storniert
läuft in die gefahr die stornogebühren
bezahlen zu müssen
für die ostersaison hieß es statt urlaub
ausgangs beschränkung weltweite
reisewarnung des anfang mai noch gilt
die empfehlung des auswärtigen amtes die
tourismusbranche fordert eine
neubewertung
wir erwarten dass demnächst auch eine
lockerung dieser reisehinweise
stattfinden wird
und da ist unsere forderung dass man
hier nicht eine weltweite reisewarnung
ausspricht sondern dezidiert schaut
welche länder sind wie betroffen
österreich überlegt bereits laut im
sommer die grenzen für deutsche zu
öffnen
die politik uneins von gar kein
tourismus über reisen nur hierzulande
bis zum möglichen mittelmeer urlaub
lauten der prognose dennoch nicht
gebucht hat dem empfehlen
verbraucherschützer abzuwarten bei
auslandsreisen nicht nur aufs auswärtige
amt zuschauer auch wenn die weltweite
reisewarnung des auswärtigen amts zum
zeitpunkt ihrer reise nicht mehr gelten
sollte
sollten sie sich trotzdem noch mal mit
dem land selbst beschäftigen ob da nicht
womöglich einreisebeschränkungen
bestehen denn dann auch dann könnte ihr
urlaub gefährdet sein wohin in diesem
sommerurlaub die frage könnte noch viel
kopfzerbrechen bereiten
zwei tipps jetzt noch in einem zdf
spezial direkt nach uns schauen die
kollegen auf die geldnot der kommunen in
der korona krise und in der zdf- heute-
app finden sie eine hochinteressante
analyse zur situation in den usa und zu
den besonderen problemen dort im
gesundheits- und sozialsystem das alles
dort zum scrollen frühlings und
vielleicht sogar sommerfeeling überall
bei uns warme temperaturen und kein
regen weit und breit für die böden und
die wälder ein problem deutschland
steuert auf ein weiteres dürre ja zu
landwirte hatten 2008 10 und 19 schon
mit enormen ernteausfällen zu kämpfen
die drohnen auch 2020 wieder vor allem
im süden und osten deutschlands ist es
besonders trocken
dadurch steigt auch die gefahr von
waldbränden thomas konsum berichtet es
brennt an der grenze zwischen den
niederlanden und deutschland ein dorf
4000 einwohner wird evakuiert und über
allem hubschrauber zum löschen
umfunktioniert hier kommt das wasser
ebenfalls nicht aus wolken sondern aus
feuerwehrschläuchen einmal ohne
niedersachsen niederschlag fehlanzeige
wie in so vielen gegenden deutschlands
die feier fressen sich in den trockenen
boden rauben land und kräfte wind und
wetter ausgesetzt
die sonne kommt von oben der wind von
der seite und die flammen von unten
kampf gegen die dürre auch auf äckern
und feldern wie in mainz viel staub
wenig ertrag fürchten landwirte
fehlende regen verheerend auch für den
forst hier nach frankfurt waldsterben
das schon vergangenes jahr begannen wir
haben eigentlich im frühjahr gehofft
dass wir durch den laub ausbruch
verbesserung kriegen auch weil es ja
eine zeitlang geregnet hat aber das hat
sich leider als drucklos erwiesen also
wir gehen davon aus dass die schäden
sich wahrscheinlich verdoppeln zu dem
was wir bisher schon haben vielmehr
müsste es regnen der stimmen
wetterexperten zu und sie sagen es gibt
den dritten zu trockenen frühling in
folge düstere aussichten auch wenn die
sonne lacht
der ausführliche wetterbericht gleich
erst nehmen wir sie noch kurz mit nach
fort myers florida
was zuerst aussieht wie ein großeinsatz
der lokalen polizei dort vor dem
krankenhaus ist vielmehr ein einziges
blinkendes dankeschön an ärzten und
pflegern in schwierigen zeiten ein herz
mit dem wir diese sendung beschließen
fast denn erst gibt es noch die
lottozahlen und die laut 9 13 29 34 39
49 superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5
57 ja dürre ist da haben wir gerade
gehört das bleibt weiterhin zu trocken
und sehr sonnig mehr hat gleich besten
terry ich empfehle in den kollegen claus
kleber im heute journal gegen 22 uhr und
kann ihnen versichern dass wir auch
morgen um 19 uhr pünktlich wieder für
sie da sind für das große interesse ein
herzliches dankeschön von uns sein und
machen sie sich wo immer das geht ein
angenehm haben
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter es ist derzeit
warm und viel zu trocken und in den
nächsten tagen geht das auch noch so
weiter wir haben es hier mit einem
umfangreichen hoch zu tun
bisher kam der wind kräftig aus
östlichen richtungen das hat den boden
noch weiter ausgetrocknet dass hoch
bleibt uns noch und somit auch der
sonnenschein
schauen wir auf die nacht da gibt es
kaum eine wolke meist stern klar überall
ein grad im osten und 10 grad am
niederrhein
morgen verbreitet viel sonnenschein fast
überall
ja und der wind ist nicht mehr so
kräftig wie in den letzten tagen entlang
der küsten gibt es einige wolken mehr
aber da fällt kein regen heraus
temperaturen erreichen höchstwerte bis
zu 25 grad im südwesten generell im
westen um die 24 grad teilweise am kürzt
noch an der ostsee bei 16 grad
die nächsten tage am freitag noch einmal
ein sommertag bis 25 grad viel
sonnenschein
von nordwesten kommt etwas kühlere luft
zu uns ja und das wochenende ist
zumindest im norden etwas kühler
damit ein schöner abend